the trailer for the third Wolverine film
well second if he refused to count x-men
origins wolverine like the rest of us
was just released well this movie
doesn't come out until March third 2017
we're breaking down the first trailer to
see what we can learn about the upcoming
film the film Logan takes place in the
future but unlike x-men days of future
past this isn't a world where sentinels
are hunting down mutants left and right
however it does seem like all of Logan's
x-men friends are dead a scene with
Logan drinking in a cemetery maybe the
answer to that obviously since we're in
the future Logan is older and not in his
prime during a few scenes in the trailer
we see Logan has scars on his knuckles
and back and even a scene where his face
is beet enough implying that his healing
factor is completely gone or not what it
used to be Professor X introduces Logan
to a young girl named Laura he tells
Logan that Laura is a lot like him she's
being hunted and needs Logan's help this
is what the film will revolve around
turning it into essentially one lung
escort mission however because laura is
a mutant she won't be completely useless
we catch our first glimpse of one of the
villains for the film the cyborg Donald
price and his group the Reapers this
group of cyborgs is known for their
hatred of mutants we briefly see them
holding down the mutant Caliban he's a
mutant who consents and track other
meals which is the perfect tool for the
Reavers finally we catch a quick glimpse
of someone with claws attacking Logan
could this be Laura because she also has
claws we know she can fight as we get to
see her kick some butt earlier in the
trailer if so what causes her to turn on
her protector will learn more about Hugh
Jackman's final ride into the sunset as
Wolverine when Logan hits theaters on
March third 2017 for more of your
favorite comic books TV shows and movies
keep it tuned to gamespot universe